former labor cabinet minister Alan
Milburn has quit the government's social
mobility commission saying that Teresa
may lacks the commitment to make Britain
Fira in his resignation letter he warned
of increasing anger and resentment
thanks to two decades of lost wage
growth which is creating a breeding
ground for populism to discuss that and
much more as well at what do I know by
the Shadow Chancellor John McDonnell
very good morning to you
shall we start with with Alan Milburn
and what appears to be the demise of the
social mobility Commission but what is
your view in all of this do you
recognise some truth and and mr.
Milburn's words that that brexit is the
priority and and not improving a lot of
societies Teresa may promised in the the
doorstep of number 10 it's important
though it's not just Alan that's
resigned that it looks as though it's
the whole commissions for that and
that's a cross-party resignation then I
think he's right Betsy is dominating
government agenda right I just wonder if
the budget was the last straw as well
because we were expecting quite a bit of
this budget in terms of well tackling
the education cuts that were people
experiencing at the moment 5,000
headteachers wrote to the Prime Minister
and asked them to halt the cuts and that
didn't happen it's the same really
investment in skills and well wage
levels are so low now and predicted to
stagnate for the next number of years as
well so I can understand the frustration
that brexit is dominating the agenda but
nothing else has moved either not just
because of brexit just because even in
the budget they couldn't address the
real issues well let's let's move on to
your brief and of course you'd be
tooling the city of Leyte speaking to
banker speaking to fund managers and
essentially going house to house saying
you know labor is your friend does that
make you feel uncomfortable for lunch no
I never take a free lunch I never
accepted lunch it's usually cups of tea
and I pay for the tea no I've been to
I've been doing this for two years now
in this brief so I've been meeting lots
of people both in the city age fund
managers asset managers but I've also
been out on the shop floor as well
meeting workers themselves and
management I went to a tech fair the
other week about robotics issues like
that and it's trying to say this is what
we're trying to do this is what our
plans are being completely open with
people and taking their ideas on board
as well but has the charm of things have
been been entirely
successful in Morgan Stanley this week
telling their investors the Jeremy
Corbyn a bigger threat to business at
them for exit provoking for looking at
this response from from mr. Corbin it's
a growing movement of well over half a
million members and a government in
waiting that will work for the many so
when they say we're a threat they're
right we're a threat to a damaging and
failed system that's rigged for the few
how does that help your case let me just
go back on it's not a charm offensive it
is as being absolutely straight with
people this is what our plans are we
want to listen to people to say what's
your view on that and we'll take a lot
of views on board as well and we'll
adjust our plans accordingly Morgan
Stanley the reason Jeremy reacted that
way Morgan Stanley is an outlier and to
come out with the christams that they
did was a bit shocking because that's
not the response we're getting at the
moat and remember as well I have to say
make this point Morgan Stanley and have
been contributing to the Conservative
Party for quite a while so they are
supporters or our political opponents I
understand that but I am happy to sit
down with Morgan Stanley so what are you
genuine criticisms because I don't think
they realize what we're about I think
you've got your iPod at your own kind
somewhere about your passings I do want
to get into the detail of your figures
examining the rationale of what is one
has to admit you know fairly striking
economic policy portfolio can we start
with corporation tax because there is a
very clear difference between the
government and the opposition they say
cut two points to 17% you say raised by
by 7% what's the thinking there well we
believe at this point in time and I
wanted this to happen in this budget you
do not give tax giveaways to the
corporations and the wealthy whilst your
public services are suffering so I could
have said being neutral at 19 percent
but you know what we said as we'll go
back to well not even the level of the
last Labour government and that still
keep us competitive with the rest of
Europe and America in particular but
what we're saying is we all have to pay
our way in this situation and we cannot
stop I just give this example in this
budget what the government has done is
given another 4.7 billion in tax cuts by
reducing the bank levy to the bankers
when when the before the kebab budget
itself charities and local government
wrote to the Chancellor since the most
vulnerable children our society are at
risk we need 2 billion by 2020 now is
not the time to be given tax cuts to the
wealthy the banks incorporated we will
get on to some some of those topics in a
bit more detail but just just focusing
on corporation tax I mean you say that
the the would raise what roughly around
220 billion pounds now that does make
sense
though the Treasury says 1% would raise
two point three two point seven billion
you multiply it you factor in inflation
under roughly nineteen point four
billion but isn't that just a bit of a
back of a [ __ ] packet calculation that
assumes that there'll be no change to
behavior you know at high rates of tax
return on investment isn't reduce of
reduced meaning less investment less
growth less take two issues there one is
if you look at the grade book which I
tossed at our manifest and I published
in a grade book alongside the
conservators didn't by the way we also
said we didn't sure that there was tax
avoidance measures brought in to ensure
that there was any change in behavior
their own tax avoidance exactly but I
also put if you look at it over four
billion in terms of flexibility so that
we had a bit of a buffer in case not
everything came in the economic
consensus is yes the corporation tax
wise will raise money in the first year
after that it gets a little bit Julie
because of the changes in pleasure and
remember we are coming to great romanian
we have communion raising corporation
tax by seven percent
an important where does that make us
more attractive well we're we're as
competitive as we were before in terms
of relationship with the rest of Europe
and America because we're going nowhere
near that the rates elsewhere so we'll
still be competitive but the graceless
out you said there was a consensus but
it's quite the reverse we had large
numbers I think there was a hundred and
thirty economists who wrote in saying
actually we support these prices fix
well not no the Institute of big
business well no actually the IMF and
others have actually said now's the time
when you shouldn't be cutting taxes in
this way and you should be investing but
isn't that a fundamental that whenever
whenever we see a rise in corporation
tax its people not companies that
ultimately bear the burden either the
company has worked well which means
shareholders lose out the company loses
its prices consumers lose out or wages a
reduced staff are laid off the work
force and what's so interesting if you
look at what's happened the government
has cut cooperation
and now we have corporations sitting on
earned income of around about five
hundred and ninety billion not investing
so actually the the promotion of tax
cuts to encourage investment hasn't
worked and what we need to do now ensure
we have a fair taxation system we're not
asking you know we're asking for the
earth we're asking them to pay their way
a bit more well let's stick with tax
showing turn turn to income tax and your
plans on that involved what both cuts
and Rises yes it was we said the top
five percent will need to pay a bit more
and again I think that's been generally
recommended by mostly economic
institutions and the IMF OECD and others
saying we need fair taxation systems now
if we're gonna afford our public
services but isn't there a point at
which you save you know it was sort of
in fact is that a point to which you say
enough is enough you're saying we're
just asking for a little bit extra I
mean can you guarantee that you wouldn't
go beyond fifty said that we've said
that because what we if you look at our
manifesto we said for the only that top
five percent would we increase if we set
out the levels we're very clear on that
and we say for the remainder there will
be no increase in income tax or v80 or
national insurance again I mean the
costing you know six point four billion
is what you say would be really would be
raised from from income tax and that
works so only if you just go to the
spreadsheet and change the 45 to a fifty
it assumes again no change top rihanna's
are going to be reducing the taxable
income as a result of that figure isn't
the figure is just not well I'm prove
they are accurate and they were tested
and if you look at what has been said in
terms of the support we've had it means
that Labor's proposal would raise is
highly uncertain if no one changed their
behavior in response it degrades around
certain billion a year some of those
affected we'd respond by reducing the
taxable incomes I'm back and yes and
that's why we put in there measures to
ensure that we just have the tax
avoidance and tax evasion and we put a
buffer in as well the IFS disagree with
just on that one point if you look at
other economists they came out in our
support okay in terms of the tax take
post post labor rises we're all talking
what roughly forty eight point six
billion again and again you know the IFS
challenged that estimate they in fact
came up with a figure of 41 billion
which in their view was a most
interesting you know because we looked
at the IFS figures they said there was
about nine billion difference one of the
things that they saw that they said
very jet there 41 billion was a very
generous estimate so no I was a greater
service nine billion the greatest
respect to the IFS that was contested by
large numbers of other institutions as
well there's economists but if you look
at what they were saying for example
they were saying the property tax would
not would not bring in a penny that
overseas companies only properties in
this country country they operate in
Singapore they operate in Canada they
operate across the world so we pointed
to them and we've said to the officer
look at that dialogue with you they also
contested other matters but actually if
you look at the buffer that I put in
there there was enough to tackle those
issues okay so you don't recognize the
IFS figures at least on that very
specific on that specific point I'll
concede I mean your only figures have a
habit of changing pretty rapidly back in
March Rebecca long Bailey claimed that
reversing conservative changes to
corporation tax capital gains
inheritance tax and the bank levy would
raise roughly seventy billion pipes that
was in March when you publish a
manifesto in me you know those four
measures plus scrapping the money
person's tax allowance would rates
twenty three point 1 billion pounds I
mean even when you're using good ones no
no that's not true
the issue was there the projection over
a number of years that long Bailey was
using when we went to the mat when we
went to the general election itself we
leave topics again along the course look
at those look at the gradebook look at
the gradebook that's what we published
in the manifesto and that's what we
stand by and those projections those
projections were made on the basis of
figures coming from the government
itself the OPR and the House of Commons
library but in two months you go from
seventy billion to twenty three billion
seventy billion was a projection of a
number of years if you look at if you
look at the grade book that's what we
went to the people on that's what we
stand by okay well let me just say on
the IFS there may well have been
differences on that just give you one
example there example is that when you
invest in the economy they discount the
multiplier effect
firstly every other economist doesn't
they believe there will be a multiplier
effect from the investment that we put
in there and in that way you see there
are differences between equal economists
about how you calculate this we took the
view expressed to us by a large nerve
economist that our figures not only was
sound but we're conservative estimate
but just on or on borrowing to invest I
mean you're talking about the fiscal
multiplied of one to one you say it
essentially paid for its down the
original scheme but in general you have
argued that the scheme pays for itself
you'll inverse rates are low at the
moment you know you spend no you reap
the benefits now that makes sense
according to Q have generally received
economic wisdom in circumstances where
you know you're emerging from recession
where interest rates are anchored close
to zero I mean that's where you see one
to one or even two to one actually we're
close to full employment global monetary
policy is tightening at the moment
financial sector is lending again a
large fiscal stimulus of the type that
you're talking about it's far more
likely to feed into hide inflation well
let's go to the capital investment fund
that we put forward we suggested a
program of two hundred and fifty billion
investment by the state over a ten-year
program ok nothing untoward what's been
seen in the past it depends on the
individual schemes that you invested in
become which you get the return I give
you the example of one scheme Crossrail
for the Northlands 10 billion calculated
not by us but independently that would
gain something like ninety billion
investment in that region that's the
sort of investment we're going for
investment wisely chosen that get a
return pay for themselves in the long
run but stimulate the economy and it
wasn't your plan to get rid of the
deficit and day to day pipe at the end
of the fight and what's the plan for
debt what we're saying is the debt to
GDP ratio which is the important and
that shows where you can pay for it will
be down within the life of a department
I mean we take all of these things stood
by the ifs just a minute challenge was
tested viability on that point that was
tested by the ifs and the ifs and just
listening to you mean on cooperation
tanks I mean you can you can argue
against it but the view of many people
is you know it works in principle but
unfortunately there will be behavioral
changes a semester repo situation with
income to nationalization
but that's why reports let me just
address that assertion you made that's
why we've addressed behavioural changes
within the program that we put forward
both in terms of tax avoidance and
evasion and also a buffer in buffer over
significant some in that program not not
to the skill that would be required to
kind of to make the ballot it's a
greatest respect other economists
believe it was
including joseph stiglitz the nobel
prize woman what more do you want from
that righty Joe I don't have a Nobel
Prize I'm not gonna be challenging him
directly but nationalization that yeah
and nationalization that you bristled
when you've been asked this question in
the past why wouldn't why isn't that a
figure being put on it we all understand
that the figure will shift depending on
the share price and other factors but
why don't you just tell us how much it
would cost right now because the debate
is about whether or not it is
cost-effective mm-hmm and you know as
well as I do as soon as any figure is
bandied about you then do something else
this morning but figures your party well
the tailless hangs on about the fact the
universe was only fully costed wait
there's a big hole in it no there isn't
a big hole that debate around when you
acquire an asset that is a valued asset
it pays for itself because it is an
earning asset that therefore covers the
cost of nationalization itself so for
example let's take rail mr. taine rail
we're saying on rail that we will so we
will read nationalize it on the base of
the front when the franchise's end so
it's cost effective when east coast line
was brought into the public sector and
managed efficiently it paid into the
Treasury of billion the government's now
having to bail out these coastline again
at cost most probably of two billion
what we're saying is bring it into
public ownership as being managed more
effectively it will pay for itself in it
wasn't it British Rail that missed the
boat and electrification and also the
greater the respect goes it's respect
that past research has demonstrated the
lack of investment in British Rail but
actually was a it was operating as
effectively as it could with that level
of nationalization does not mean that
poor did business decision will not be
cheap well with the greatest respect if
you look at the East Coast and yeah
there is really need to respect my views
as well which is one when you look at
the examples in rail where it's been
brought back into public operation both
in these coastline and conics was the
last one the southeast the most
efficient services provided within our
railway system and at the same time all
I'm asking for is pretty much what it
costs today to do what you'll be causing
at some point if you cost free because
it pays for itself it will that's it's
still a commitment in terms of
government spendings well you get an
income from the operation of the service
presuming that it once we're all I'm
asking
for it's a figure I'm giving you the
example and giving the example east
coast line here's a concrete example
it's been brought back into public
ownership it's operated effectively paid
money into the Treasury it gets reprieve
a-- ties and then what happens we left
with possibly a two billion pound bill
hmm so that demonstrates how effective
it could be in terms of public sector
play against something which would which
you've identified as something which
resonates with the public and and it
does clearly I mean you've long
maintained that the public sector pickup
needs lifting how much is that going to
cause we've cost it within the thing we
looked at we looked at the cost side
against the OVR figures and we've said
that it will rise with the level of
above inflation of those crossings that
the OPR have said and we put that in the
grade book itself again what we're also
saying is that would be subject to
negotiations we're not gonna interfere
in those negotiations but the most
important thing is to lift the paper but
but in essence you are committing right
now to a real terms pay increase across
the public saying it costed it in our
grade book manifesto commitments what we
said was we took the OPR figures on what
would be the rate of increase within the
economy overall of wages we costed that
and we said if you lift up a cap that
would be the cost of however that's
subject to negotiation on deficit
reduction i have to admit i've got i've
got a bit of confusion in terms of what
the policy is you me you said yeah
absolutely
eliminate the day-to-day deficit spend
by the end of five years what you'll be
inheriting a day-to-day deficit warned
you or on current figures we estimate
and this is in the new around about 20
25 billion possibly more now that's on
possibly more now that's on top of the
50 billion or of additional tax rises
that you're putting into place just
among the 50 boot the 48.6 paid for
themselves the tax rise has come in
they'll pay for the public services
let's cost neutral when you come to the
deficit itself what we're saying is we
will not borrow for day-to-day
expenditure but what we will do is
ensure that we borrow foreign investment
overall and that investment will cover
its own cost because the rate of
investment will give us a return on that
investment so therefore a we believe
over five year old in program will be
able to bring that deficit down how do
you do it you do what this government
doesn't do you invest in the economy you
grow the economy and in that way the
debt to GDP ratio comes down
turn to the point they made a few
minutes ago I mean the idea that you
know massive fiscal stimulus at this
point in our economic cycle is going to
be paid for by itself just doesn't stack
up with the economists that religious
situations in the past one I think you
can choose I think you're confusing two
things one is on day to day expenditure
mm-hmm we will ensure we do not borrow
full stop any day-to-day expenditure
will be covered by the tax increases
we've brought about which is larger on
corporations and the rich and the top 5%
no it seems to think that they will
raise the amount that you claim you've
just said it again
no one says terrific one organization
query one element of our overall I Tunes
130 and others economists supported it
so what I'm saying to you out there and
this isn't just me IMF another always
idiot now saying you've got to invest
now if we don't invest will have the
same productivity crisis that we're
facing at the month that's why this
governor has failed is capitalism
inherently wrong what are you just the
man to fix it well what we want to do is
transform them all economic model that
we've got at the moment and the economic
model at the moment is to short-term
does not distribute the resources and
the benefits fairly and at the same time
is too based regionally in the London
the southeast what we're trying to say
is you take a long-term view and invest
you make sure that investment goes all
over the country no one is left behind
no or air is left behind and then when
we build a prosperous economically and
environmentally sustainable economy
those rewards that prosperity is shared
by everybody so you're the man to fix
capitalism we're the party that will go
into government with the policies that
will transform our economy so that
everyone gains and as I say we have an
economically and environmentally
sustainable economy that prosperity's
got to be shared by every person in
every region rather than well some of
the wealthiest I promote the way it is
at the moment I don't know why you
didn't take the opportunity to claim the
mr. fixit title it certainly sounds a
bit better than spreadsheet Phil doesn't
it but anyway the title that I want the
title that I want is the person who
actually brought common sense the way we
manage our economy the way in which we
look to the long term the way we share
all the resources to around people
fairly so we go or gain from the
prosperity the investment we've put in
and that we tackle I have to say also we
tackle some of they're pouring the
appalling
treatment of some of our fellow citizens
in terms of homelessness housing
education cuts the NHS crisis that we've
got well you may very well have that
opportunity before too long let's make
Donald many thanks indeed